ei lá todos pessoal do que falar andar
que sabe o que é isto está aqui sabe o
estilo swinga não me interessa obrigado
estamos aqui para jogar com um daqueles
jogos que tati prendemos nuno que está
pelo que nos dizem este jogo empurrado
cueca que eu quero nem falar só para
machucar star game neste jogo contém
violência sangue e goretti bulls corpos
de excluir os que têm equipe mas já ter
sido feito ou seja tínhamos quer sustos
que você solta porque bent
entretenimento presentes indo agora foi
notável sobretudo apresente piadas
chulas por 10.000 de onde é costume
molécula mesmo fashion week a um herói
mais principais estendendo-se também
pretende aproximar e pessoal estamos
numa casa nada bonita eu não sei se
vocês também são assim mas que o outro
está numa casa vazia mas que pouco o
rosto
hoje a oi acabou após posso continuar a
discussão da casa ai isso que o ps um
bicho é esse ombro do evento e nem meu
deus meu deus
ok eu ainda agora como sul
eu tenho que lá não tem lugar melhor pra
mim olha que a mulher mar é o que diria
que o preço do dólar
olha a sua porta
o disco olha que aquilo ia pagar ao
botafogo a lei de uganda arbil agora mil
num estilo muito bom ter este jogo não
sendo eu a se chamar aqui olha as minhas
por ser o menos mau é menos mal que elas
deixaram que a sad é e da tua mãe eu não
sou o pai mas fui e 11 em cima meu
enquanto estava a dormir e isso fará
você deu a meu deus meu não
o objetivo foi dar leite torno do
eléctrico 28
eu acho que é por aqui tem que levantar
esta tampa será cap pelo esgoto não não
funciona quando as consideraram ataque
nem há exatamente é estudar que tudo
parece um explorador do dom é este aqui
mais fácil crescer na empresa é tudo
isso embora pareça funcionou a caixa
legal elogia agora que eu tenho que
fazer é porque olha que estas caló uma
escada eu sabia que eu era um explorador
qualquer coisa tira o carro é meu deus
está tudo bem eu sei que tá não tem
esgoto em desordem ok então quero ter
que fazer também criou ir lá pra baixo
ou arrombar a porta não funciona um bar
não dá a demora tempo atrás tempo atrás
não consegui ir além do que irá tomar
nota
e é isso ai é o espera lá dar que o
expurgo para caraças sublinhasse max da
globo já consegui dar a volta também ó
exatamento oxigênio posso passar se no
ferro não há eu baixo sangster em um
estágio tão paquistão segundo trabalho
vamos tentar esta porta estava não não
funciona
eu acho que por aqui né são canais morte
ai sabe que sai daquele centro não
funciona pega pela polícia que qualquer
coisa
o preço-teto pico roubar o ouro já tem
uma arma pessoal só teve um pecado
tourinho aqui neste palco estacionamento
andar ganha que perto da mídia o que
escuro meia não vou entrar aqui o hotel
se não eu não quero mas vai ter que ser
não vai ter que entrar aqui rainha
conectar pronto fechou ontem tava
infantis dentro nightmare deurick dreno
[ __ ] se
mas por que raio já que a nossa filha
deveria estar neste hotel neste motel
ele foi embora estes quadros e que
oferece uma batata mulher sangue no chão
páginas riscadas uma fala fazer faísca
muita coisa pra normal aqui neste motel
entramos no quarto né
olha pra cama tudo antes feita não sabem
armar as cargas que é isto
então este quadro era de um sem-abrigo
né meu deus um colchão dois colchões e
epá alguém gritou que não houve violação
da lei e da lei né não o xinguei no
sequeiro terruá precisam cantar um pois
é preciso uma chave preciso que casa eu
preciso tudo aqui
o que precisamos fazer aqui abrir esta
porta e é claro o envolvimento da quinta
pesquisa tinha que ser esta a porta
o tempo livre em relação ao mandar um
partido muito giro
muitos de vocês são oposição é que ela
vamos lá punha o telemóvel embora a não
é o cartão aquilo baixo tipo ainda lá
isso em escala agora não circula muita
calma
o embarque para la paz o cartão basta só
isso
chega desse tipo de quebra só que aí
possa mexer nas câmeras também o seu
amigo tô eu eu só que o governo divulgou
que vai transmitir o bochum
ele vai transmitir meira não conseguir
ver que está tudo escuro aportar na
psicose
agora consigo até porque você vai passar
agora eu tenho que fazer por onde e
porquê porque não foi entre isso ai ai
jesus jesuíta for cos aia por onde agora
estamos a falar aqui morro que vão
morrendo
não é porque eu não criei meu deus
o salve salve
eu estava em falta
a prova quase o caraças não vai pegar
quem tenta fazer campanha a fazer é eu
estava no meu ouvido é comer morangos
acabou já que o país só vão chegar
primeiro espero que vocês tenham gostado
já sabem quanto você que favorito fiquem
bem até a próxima rodada